and speaking of horrible narratives um
donald trump has been out there over the
last few days
scribbling down his little idiotic you
know statements as fast as he can having
his spokeswoman liz harrington uh tweet
them out
and of course most of them have been
about afghanistan you know trying to lay
all of this squarely at the feet of joe
biden but in one of his statements which
i'm about to read
he actually said something else he
blamed biden for another surrender not
just allegedly surrendering to the
taliban here it is
first joe biden surrendered to covid and
it's come roaring back
then he surrendered to the taliban who
has quickly overtaken afghanistan and
destroyed confidence in american power
and influence the outcome in afghanistan
including the withdrawal would have been
totally different if the trump
administration had been in charge who or
what will joe biden surrender to next
someone should ask him if they can find
him yeah says the guy that spent like 25
of his presidency not at the white house
if they can find him
well we know where to find you golf dude
you're probably hitting the link
somewhere right actually you're probably
sitting in a dark room just scribbling
these things out as fast as you can like
liz get those out
now
i've addressed the afghanistan stuff
but surrendering to covid
that's just plain idiotic
now don't get me wrong
i have not been shy
about criticizing the biden
administration when they deserve to be
criticized
it's what i do and i'm not going to stop
doing that
but their response to kovid
no i'm sorry
that's not something that i've
criticized
because they've done a pretty dang good
job have they been perfect no
there's a couple of things they've done
or said that i've disagreed with
uh for example you know uh when they
first came out said we're gonna get all
the kids back in school yeah i thought
at the time you know what it's a little
too soon and hey of course look where
we're at now
but to say he surrendered to covid
this coming from the guy that once told
people to inject bleach
coming from the same guy who said we'd
have zero cases
by april 2020 that we would be reopened
by easter of 2020 the guy who downplayed
the pandemic every possible chance he
got accusing another person of
surrendering to the virus
that's just plain nuts
and here's the thing yeah we got a surge
of covet in this country
but in no way is that joe biden's fault
no way at all i'm sorry but it's not
the fault right now
lies with the anti-massacres
it lies with the anti-vaxxers and of
course it lies with any governor
regardless of party
that is not allowing their cities or
school districts to implement mass
mandates
and actually all of those republicans
happen to be uh or excuse me all those
governors happen to be republicans
so that's actually where we're at right
now
the only people in this country that
have surrendered to kovid
are those republican leaders who
continue to surrender
to the nuttiest people in their states
the most misinformed people in their
states
we have seen polls show that a majority
of americans support mass mandates
furthermore polls have also shown that a
majority of americans would be okay with
vaccine passports and vaccine
mandates
even people who aren't vaccinated
support
vaccine passports
so we know there is not a ton of
disagreement about the fact that we need
to take care of each other
but that hasn't stopped these republican
governors people like ron desantis greg
abbott asa hutchinson
all of them
have banned mass mandates in their
states
and now we're also seeing massive covet
surges in the republican controlled
state of mississippi under republican
governor tate reeve
reeves who came out the other day
and actually said that covid and kids is
basically just the sniffles
less than 24 hours later an 8th grader
in mississippi
died of covid
nobody has surrendered to covid except
for the republicans
the biden administration has done a
great job here in the united states of
getting vaccines out there they have
done a great job of coming in and taking
care of these red states
after they've had to admit oh no we
can't handle it
you're sending 300 more ventilators down
here to the state of florida because our
hospitals are overwhelmed over in i
think it's texas they're you know
building these new coveted beds
in a parking garage
mississippi hospitals filling up alabama
hospitals filling up georgia hospitals
filling up
and of course texas and florida seeing
it too
and biden's been there every step of the
way
biden has been supportive
of the school districts and counties
that are defying these republican
governors and putting mass mandates in
place
all that's left for biden to do at this
point is make a nationwide mass mandate
which by the way he already did for uh
federally funded forms of public
transportation
he has not surrendered to covid in the
least
the republicans have their idiotic
policies followed with their idiotic
talking points casting doubt about the
effectiveness of the vaccine casting
doubt about the effectiveness of masks
that is what is fueling the coveted
surge in the united states today and
none of that is the fault of joe biden
that fault rests on the shoulders of the
republicans who have decided to
politicize this pandemic
that is what is going on in the united
states today and trump absolutely has
just infuriated me
trying to suggest otherwise
i am farin cousins i'm sitting in for
david pakman we've got a lot more
wonderful stories coming up and don't
forget follow me on all my social media
accounts at fahren balanced we'll be
right back with more
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most innovative
shower head it uses only about half the
water that other shower heads do saving
you money helping the environment but
it's actually a lot more powerful than
other shower heads on the market it has
twice the coverage of other shower heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up really easy and it's been a
totally different experience than any
other shower head i've used i can get in
and out of the shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off so i was actually amazed that
it's only using about half as much water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match perfectly with the design of
the shower head the shower head starts
at just 199 and you'll get 10 percent
off all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video